ما هي التكتيكات العسكريه
والعمليات التي ينتهجها جيش الاحتلال في
خان
يونس سلمى هناك حجد كبير من القوات
الاسرائيليه او جيش الاحتلال ما يقارب
الثمانيه الويه فيها وحدات خاصه الايجوز
والمجاني عنها خلال التقرير هذه الوحدات
هي مخصصه للعمليات الخاصه جلان على سبي
على سبيل المثال للحصر كانت تعمل في العمق
اللبناني هي تعمل خلف خطوط العدو بالنسبه
لها والايجو هي المخصصه
لقتال المدن والشوارع اليوم الجهد الرئيسي
للقوات الاسرائيليه هي في الشمال غرب وفي
جنوب مدينه خانيونس حتى محاوله قطع
المدينه عن مخيم خانيونس وفتح الطريق
باتجاه رفع فاذا نحن امام مرحله من حرب
المدن تستعمل فيها هذه القوات الخاصه
تستعمل الكثير الكثير من المسيرات عدنا
الى استعمال المسيرات لعده اسباب اولا
تستعمل لجمع المعلومات نقل واقع المعركه
والميدان وقد تستعمل في بعض الاوقات ل
كعمليه انتحاريه لاستهداف بعض المقاومين
ولكن في خان يونس الجبهه الشرقيه عبسان
عبسان الجديده وخزاعه هناك عمليه تسبيت
لجبار المقاومه على الانتشار
وعدم يعني جعلها ان تساند المعركه حول خان
يونس الهدف المطلق والاساسي هو المدينه
الرهائن يعتقد انهم هناك قيادات حماس
وبالتالي اذا سقطت خانيونس يفتح الباب
امام رفح وبالتالي تصبح قطاع غزه مقسم
مقسم الى اربعه او خمسه اقسام معزوله عن
بعضها البعض وما هي المعايير التي عندها
يمكن
لجيش الاحتلال ان يقول بان خان يونس باتت
بيده هنا المشكله الكبرى التكتيكيه
العملات
والاستراتيجيه يعني ليس هناك من قدره على
قياس النجاح يعني متى تقول الفرقه 98 انها
حققت هدف معين لماذا سلمى لانه القرار
السياسي وضع اهداف ضمن كادر معين لن يتز
زح عنها هي كبيره جدا ولكن واقع الميدان
عكس امور صعبه التحقيق من هنا هذا القرار
السياسي لم يتغير فاذا كل قرار او كل
انجاز يعتقد انه حققه الجيش الاسرائيلي لا
يطابق الاهداف السياسيه يعتبر خساره اليوم
وهذا على سبيل المثال للحصر ايضا يعني
اليوم غيرت جغرافيه القتال طبوغرافيه
القتال وحتى هندسه القتال في في قطاع غزه
فقط بواسطه الانفاق وهذا ما يذكرنا بالعام
2002 في مخيم بلاطه عندما قاتل جيش
الاحتلال من بيت الى بيت
عبر
احداث فجوات في المنازل هو قاتل داخل
المنازل ليغير جغرافيه وهندسه القتال
اليوم المقاومه في غزه غيرت هندسه القتال
هناك المساحه الفوقيه المساحه ما تحت
الارض الانفاق وحتى الابنيه لهذا السبب
عميد الياسي يلجا جيش الاحتلال الى نصف
مربعات سكنيه بحالها في مثلا منطقه خان
يونس هو يبدا بعمليه التماس مع المقاومه
اذا تعذر التقدم كما حصل وهذا درس من مقتل
21 جندي في منطقه يعني ال في وسط القطاع
عندما دمر المبنى هو يقوم بالتماس اذا كان
هناك من مقاومه يطلب اما المسيرات اما
الدعم الجوي وبالتالي عمليه التدمير او
قوات الهندسه بالاضافه الى الدي 9 يعني
الدي 9 هذه الجرافه طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي
مؤخرا 100 دي 9 للاضافه الى سلاح الهندسه
ومنها ما يعمل اليا اتونس يعني دون سائق
ودون عنصر حمايه ولكن ما الفائده اذا لم
يتغير المشهد في القتال ان كان في الشمال
منذ بدء العمليات البريه وصولا الان الى
الجنوب مرورا بالمنطقه الوسطى بعد كل هذه
الايام من العمليات البريه لازالت كتائب
القسام وكتائب سرايا القدس يعني تستطيع ان
تنفذ ذات العمليات من التحام مباشر ومن
استهداف للدبابات وناقلات الجند والجنود
الافراد ايضا يعني يعني حتى تطوير
التكتيكات المتبعه لجيش الاحتلال لم تعطي
اي نتيجه ونشاهد هذا على
الفيديوهات جيش الاحتلال يتعلم من التجربه
ولكن المقاومه ايضا تتعلم من التجربه لكل
مسرح من المسارح ان كان في الشمال الوسط
وخان يونس هناك طريقه معينه حسب الواقع
الميداني وحسب الاهميه اليوم هدف الجيش
الاسرائيلي وجيش الاحتلال ج منطقه خان
يونس كما شمال غزه او مدينه غزه انتقال
الى المرحله الثالثه يكون بذلك انتقل في
الشمال في الوسط وفي خان يونس الى المرحله
الثالثه ينشئ هذه المنطقه الامنه وبالتالي
ينتقل الى المرحله الرابعه ولكن يبقى
امرين مهمين وهما المعضله الاساسيه
بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال الانفاق الرهائن
والصواريخ التي تضرب الداخل الاسرائيلي